[Música]
vamos a irnos hoy hasta Venezuela para
ahondar con nuestra corresponsal Daniela
Zambrano en la situación política de
Cara a las elecciones presidenciales de
2024 este jueves el presidente de la
asamblea nacional el chavista Jorge
Rodríguez afirmó que no se permitirá la
entrada a ninguna misión de verificación
de la Unión Europea a quien acusó de
colonialista la advertencia llega luego
de que el parlamento europeo calificará
de arbitraria e inconstitucional la
decisión de inhabilitar a opositores al
gobierno Daniela Buenas noches qué más
ha dicho Rodríguez al respecto y Cuáles
han sido las reacciones a lo interno
tras el pronunciamiento del presidente
del parlamento
fue una declaración bastante subida de
tono plagada de improperios hacia los
parlamentarios europeos los calificó de
imbéciles groseros colonialistas
advirtió que no iba a permitir que no se
iba a permitir el ingreso una misión de
observación electoral para las
presidenciales en Venezuela previstas
para 2024 y se dirigió directamente a
Joseph Morel el acto representante para
los asuntos exteriores de la Unión
Europea dijo que habían violado el
acuerdo refiriéndose a no injerencia por
parte de órganos y extranjeros esta
declaración de Jorge Rodríguez sea el en
hemiciclo de sesiones en la sede de la
asamblea nacional y también rechazaron
que la Unión Europea haya exigido la
Constitución de un consejo nacional
electoral equilibrado reacciones al
interno ha habido por parte de
organizaciones no gubernamentales
defensoras de Derechos Humanos como
prove que han dicho que en Venezuela
sigue consolidándose el camino para
otras elecciones presidenciales sin
garantías recordemos que es una
exigencia de la oposición venezolana que
haya misión de observación internacional
en unos comicios para garantizar que
sean unas elecciones libres e
independientes pero Daniela pero vamos a
poner ahora un poco en contexto a
nuestra audiencia Cuál ha sido la
relación de estas misiones europeas con
el gobierno venezolano en los últimos
años
hace una reacción una relación bastante
difícil recordemos que la misión de
observación electoral de la Unión
Europea estuvo en Venezuela para los
comicios regionales de finales de 2021
sin embargo luego de su visita en la que
los observadores hicieron fuertes
recomendaciones al gobierno de Nicolás
maduro para que hubiera independencia de
poderes para que cesaran las
inhabilitaciones la persecución a los
dirigentes políticos estos observadores
tuvieron que salir de forma abrupta del
país porque no se les renovaron las
visas y posteriormente en una locución
el presidente Nicolás Maduro los
calificó de espías ellos incluso
tuvieron que presentar el informe final
sobre las recomendaciones de esas
elecciones en ese momento fuera de
Venezuela no se les permitió Volver al
país en esa oportunidad antes de eso
Venezuela había pasado 15 años sin que
una observación de El parlamento europeo
pisar a territorio venezolano la última
fue en 2006 Entonces ha sido una
relación bastante difícil y no se
descartan otras reacciones incluso por
parte del presidente Nicolás Maduro
luego de que la Unión Europea condenara
las inhabilitaciones a las opositores